thank Stephen and thanks to the
organizers this is the mic working can
you hear me okay cool so this is joint
work with several of my colleagues at
deep mind and essentially it doesn't
directly overlap with the theme of the
workshop but I think it has implications
so the the work is really about taking
all these complex machine learning
models that we're building using deep
learning algorithms and trying to make
sure that they satisfy desirable
properties that we would like them to
satisfy given the domains that we are
applying them and and if you imagine the
predictions of these algorithms being
part of real time decision-making
systems it's important that you have a
priori checks on the that that give you
guarantees that they will be doing the
right things under all circumstances so
that's really what this work is about so
many of you might have heard about the
recent fatality is unfortunate with the
Tesla's of self-driving cars and and and
uber ones and essentially what this kind
of drives towards is the need to have
much stronger safety checks on the
systems we build using data-driven AI
technologies and to really understand
the core of of where these
vulnerabilities come from I'm gonna
start my talk by looking at what machine
learning actually means and and kind of
you know making some arguments that that
show that the way machine learning is
done right now it's it's almost
inevitable that you would see things
like this happening and how we can go
from the way things are done right now
to to better way of doing things that
hopefully will reduce the chances of
things like this happening right so our
motivation is to really have ways to
check our machine learning systems and
so let's think about the motivation for
machine learning right so you can think
of machine learning as a paradigm for
for implementing certain tasks on a
computer but let's think first think
about how we would specify
tasks so let's start with something very
simple like you know you want to write a
function to sort a list this is a
specification in an informal language
it's a natural language you could turn
that into a formal specification using a
logical formula or in any kind of formal
language and what what we do in machine
learning is typically to replace this
complete specification by just
input-output examples right so we're
going to say that rather than defining
you this formula that tells me what the
right thing is to do in all possible
situations I'm just going to give you
pairs of inputs and outputs that tell me
in for those specific inputs what the
right output should be right so of
course the problem with the first type
of specification is that it's it's
ambiguous there may not be a very
precise way to translate that into
computer code a complete specification
in many tasks it's is very time
consuming and if you think of a task
like computer vision it's it's it's
almost impossible but as we know the
partial specifications especially in
high dimensional spaces if I just give
you a small set of inputs and outputs
this is a very incomplete specification
of the task at hand right so the
question is is there a middle ground
between these that somehow combines the
best of both worlds and and that's
really what we want to drive towards so
so what's what do we do in supervised
learning right so we have a bunch of
inputs and outputs in this example you
have images of cats and dogs and you
want to learn a classifier that given
the image is going to predict whether
it's a cat or a dog right and so
essentially your learning algorithm is
going to learn some kind of mapping from
X to Y that given any image will either
predict whether it's it's a K or a dog
of course if you look at the space of
images it's a very high dimensional
space and even if you have like you know
millions of data points it covers a very
small fraction of the space of all
images so in some sense trying to learn
a a complete classifier between cats and
dogs just based on a million examples of
cats and dogs it's a very under
specified task right so this is really
what supervised learning is doing given
a specification in terms of input output
example
you apply some machine learning
algorithm and you get an implementation
which is a predictor that given any new
input will predict the the label for
that of course we have you know if
you've been following the news there's
so many examples in recent years of this
kind of approach failing there is these
examples of you know people with dark
skin being labeled as guerrillas in in
Google photos there's a case of
self-driving cars crashing and then work
done here it Burt Lee is shown that you
know you can do these very mild stickers
on top of stop signs and cause neural
networks that do vision on those to
hallucinate all kinds of crazy things
you can have machine learning systems
interacting with humans and humans kind
of behaving adversarially so there was
this chat pot that Microsoft released
that after 24 hours became a Hitler
Hitler lover loving sex robot and and
they had to actually take it down openly
I built this really cool algorithm that
that does place this game of Dora but
again like they're within hours of them
releasing the code people who are able
to find situations where where the
algorithm did very strange things there
is also this increasing issue of
algorithmic bias and fairness where
essentially you're using these machine
learning algorithms to make decisions
that influence people and the algorithms
are trained on data which comes from
potentially bias systems and naturally
the models that you learn are going to
inhale inherit these biases and so
essentially you want to really have ways
to check where what kinds of biases your
algorithms might be learning and and
somehow guard yourself against these so
really what this is all getting to is
that we need much richer specifications
if we really want machine learning
algorithms to work in a wild a few
examples are listed on this slide
you you would want some kind of
robustness to adversarial perturbations
of the inputs to your models you for
some notion of fairness or unbiasness
which themselves are very tricky to
define but
say you come up with some reasonable
definition we won't waste a check there
are machine learning models are fair and
unbiased and we want ways to train our
models to be fair and unbiased if you're
applying machine learning in some
physical domain maybe you want to make
sure that the models of physics that
your machine learning models are
learning our physics compliant for
example they should satisfy conservation
of energy or momentum or any kind of
physical principles you might want right
so in today's talk I'm going to mostly
focus on the first kind of specification
which is robustness to adversarial
examples but I'm happy to talk about any
of the others we're actively looking
into all these areas okay so essentially
we want to build towards this vision of
a specification driven AI where you're
we're combining verification techniques
techniques from the formal methods
community the convex optimization
community to actually check properties
of machine learning models with the more
traditional approach of specifications
based on input out for examples but also
argumented with this robustness to
adversarial perturbations which is
essentially going to be checked by our
verification procedure in combination
with adapted learning algorithms to
essentially get a verified
implementation of our machine learning
model right so you want to learn a
classifier as well as some kind of proof
that the classifier satisfies your
specification so so let's talk about how
you might go about doing this and and
why this is hard in general and how you
you get around the hardness right so
essentially we want to look at the ways
in which machine learning models are
tested as of now typically they are
tested statistically so let's say that
you're learning some kind of neural
network which is just a layer wise
mapping between inputs and outputs given
some input is going to predict some
label and your statistical test is that
you when you're training the algorithm
you hold out some data that you don't
show the algorithm and based on this
test data you you test whether for a
large enough fraction of the data that
the algorithm has not seen in the past
it's able to classify those examples
correctly right so this is a statistical
test and if
if your model passes the statistical
test by predicting correctly on a large
enough subset of the test data you
accept it as being a fine model you can
make this test slightly harder by saying
that there may be an adversary that
corrupts your test input by a small
amount before asking you to predict and
so then the question is if if I have a
clever enough adversary can i still make
correct predictions and this is
something that's known as adversarial
testing of course both of these are
still not you know assuring you that
that should model satisfy the
specification because this test is only
as good as the adversary that you come
up with right so if I could come up with
a better adversary I could still break
the model so the question is is is
either of these tests sufficiently
secure and you know what would happen if
there is a stronger adversity and so at
nips which is one of the machine
learning conferences there is there was
this competition last year on trying to
build defenses against these kinds of
adversarial attacks and there's a
variety of techniques that were proposed
that both came from papers published in
the literature but also just submissions
to this contest and at deepmind we did
some work along with in parallel to work
that was done outside of deepmind as
well that showed that actually I'm sorry
so so this was just the redline should
not it applies to all of these models is
that essentially if you design your
defenses to be robust against a specific
adversary you can often find a stronger
adversary that actually drives the
robustness all the way down to zero so
even though there were all these models
that were actually claiming to be robust
to adversaries it was because they were
potentially using rather weak
adversaries so if you actually use
strong enough adversaries enough enough
compute you could actually break all of
these models so this really calls for
the need for worst-case guarantees which
is what we call verification and you can
think of verification at various levels
the model level what we call module
level verification is just about
verifying input-output properties of
single neural networks so think about a
neural net
that's classifying handwritten digits so
given that image of a seven it's going
to predict seven but we want to argument
this with saying this network with this
specification that says that I want to
continue to predict seven for all images
of this type so I'm going to take my
original image and I'm going to add a
small amount of noise to it and as long
as that that noise is small enough
that's that says that perceptually it
should not change the nature of the
image I want to continue to predict
seven right so my specification is that
for all my input data as long as I add
small enough noise to it of any bounded
magnitude I continue to make the same
predictions you can think about this
also at a system level where your neural
network is not being used just to make
predictions but it's being used as part
of a larger system and so you know just
to consider like a very toy example of
this maybe you want to take pairs of
digits and predict the sum of those
digits and then in this case your
specification would be to say that you
still continue to predict the correct
sum irrespective of taking any pair of
images and adding powder noise to that
pair of images right here so far okay so
of course you know this would be great
if we could do it and you know people
would already be doing it if it was very
easy the problem is that verification in
general is a very difficult problem the
most obvious way to do it is to do it by
enumeration so you could imagine
discretize using the space of all
perturbations of your image and if you
count the number of such perturbations
then it grows exponentially in the size
of the input in this case the number of
pixels of your image and you're just
going to check manually for each option
in this enumerated space of
perturbations whether your model
satisfies the specification and if it
passes this very exhaustive test then
you're going to declare it to be safe
right so if you actually compute the
amount of time it takes to actually do
this computation even for a very small
data set which is this the sameness data
set of
digits even if I allow each pixel to be
perturbed by one unit or two units up or
down I quickly reach you know a crazy
number of possibilities and you know if
you're familiar with the alphago program
even the alphago program was actually
only reasoning about something that was
about a one unit perturbation in this
space so this is a hard problem in
general it's np-hard you can show even
for single hidden layer in your network
so as long as as as soon as you have
even a single hidden layer so you have a
two layer network with a single hidden
layer it already becomes np-hard right
okay so so we're going to see how we get
around this but before that let's see
what verification could do for us
based on the algorithms that we have
developed so we're going to again look
at this Emnes classification problem and
we're going to look at the space of
epsilon perturbations of all our
training data or test data and we want
to ask the question out of all of our
test examples how many of the test
examples don't have an adversarial
perturbation within a radius of size
Epsilon right so for how many of my test
examples can I guarantee that no matter
what perturbation I do as long as it's
within this radius of size epsilon I
cannot change the classifiers output
right and so this is what we're able to
do with our current algorithms so the
black line the dark line is is an upper
bound computed by our verification
procedure that says that no matter what
adversary you had as a function of the
size of the perturbation I could not
increase the error rate on the test set
by more than the amount indicated by the
solid line the dashed line is a lower
bound that comes from a specific attack
algorithm right so so this is basically
I design a specific kind of adversary
that tries to attack the model and it's
able to increase the error rate up to a
certain point so you can see that as the
perturbation size grows the the gap
between the upper and lower bound grows
but it's still kind of at at at a
perturbation of size 30 which is roughly
10% of the gray scale on this problem we
still have reasonably tight bombs
okay so uh so how does what we do
compared to prior work I'm gonna compare
it in terms of four of these axes we're
going to look at completeness which is
the property that our verification
method is exhaustive right so either is
going to find a proof of correctness
that our model satisfies the
specification or is going to find a
counter example that shows that our
model does not satisfy the specification
complexity is computational complexity
integration with learning basically
means that we want to do this
verification but ultimately we want to
feed the results of the verification
back into the learning algorithm so that
we can learn models that satisfy the
specification that we want so is it easy
to integrate this verification algorithm
with the learning that's that's another
consideration and a lot of the
verification algorithms that were
proposed in literature before only work
with piecewise linear neural networks so
they don't handle things like sigmoids
or tranches which are transfer functions
that are used quite commonly in neural
networks and so and so that's this is
about how general a model the
verification method can handle so the
first three column first three rows here
are algorithms that came out of the
formal verification community so it's
work done by people who work on SMT and
sat solvers and and model checking in
and that kind of stuff and typically
these algorithms they focus on
completeness but they're somewhat
questionable and complexity in the sense
that there could be instances of the
problem where they take very long to
computer complete the verification this
algorithm here as well also uses integer
programming and I'm potentially
susceptible to that this year there were
a bunch of interesting algorithms that
came out from the machine learning
community that sacrifice on the
completeness but improve significantly
upon in terms of the complexity of the
algorithm and they also integrate well
with learning algorithms so they were
designed to be verification procedures
that can be folded into learning
algorithms on the other hand this this
approach does not handle piecewise non
piecewise linear neural networks and
this algorithm only applies to single in
neural networks so our approach in in
some sense generalizes to all possible
models it can integrate with learning
algorithms and it is of very acceptable
complexity and I'll actually show you
some numbers that that verify this so
note that on this slide I'm not talking
about a lot of the other work that has
been done on trying to promote
robustness to specific kinds of attacks
this is only algorithms that actually do
provable verification of new orleans so
let's think about how we might go about
doing this verification in a tractable
way so let's look at this very simple
neural network which has four inputs and
it receives inputs with some
perturbation radius of point zero one so
these two inputs are nominally 0.1 and
then they can be put up by up to point
zero one these inputs are 0.1 and minus
0.1 again can be put up by up to point
zero one they pass through a weight of
one of a unit weight so they're just
mapped as identity and then they pass
through this value non-linearity for
those of you who don't know what the
value is it's just this piecewise linear
function right so essentially it's it's
equal to zero if X is less than zero and
it's equal to X if X is positive
okay so if you--if you reason about how
what the numerical range of the output
would be you can show that this call for
this label of zero would be between 0.2
plus or minus point zero two here it
would be between point zero 1 plus or
minus point zero one and so just by
doing this simple propagation of bounds
from the inputs to the outputs you can
reason that the score for label zero
would always be larger than the score
for label one no matter what the inputs
are within this perturbation that make
sense to everyone I'm just kind of
propagating the bounds and the inputs
through the nonlinearities in this model
yes we're going to be numerical
questions they're going to be what oh
you mean like finite position type
questions yes of course yeah and and you
know here I take all unit weights but in
general your neural networks could be so
if you really wanted to do this
rigorously you would have to do exact
position arithmetic and stuff kind of
like really computing rigorous outer
bounds on all of your floating-point
operations in in our view doing that is
going to add a lot of overhead and so
far we don't we haven't seen evidence
that actually worrying about the
floating point errors makes things much
worse and and actually some of the
papers from the formal education
community have actually checked this by
using SMT solvers with with exact
precision arithmetic and comparing it
with floating-point arithmetic and and
they found that at least in many of
these problems practically doesn't make
too much of a difference
but I agree with you that to actually
get a formal proof you will have to
reason about the errors okay yes but
again like empirically it does not seem
to be the case so if you do the
verification with floating point or with
exact arithmetic it doesn't seem to
matter in other questions
so essentially this is the key idea that
we're going to use and we're going to
scale up and tighten these bounds using
ideas from duality and convex
optimization which I will explain in the
next few slides how am I on time okay so
essentially we're going to pose
verification as an optimization problem
to do that I'm going to introduce some
notation so this NN applied to X and I
refers to the confidence that the neural
network believes that input X should
receive label I so this is the score for
label I given to input X and I'm going
to call I of X the true label so the
correct label corresponding to the input
X so if this was an image of a cat I
this this is going to be the label that
says cat and I'm going to look at the
difference between the score that the
neural network gives to any other
incorrect label J as compared to the
true label and essentially the adversary
is going to try to maximize the
difference right so the adversary is
going to try to boost the lay the score
for some incorrect label Delon related
to the correct label and so I can pose
the adversary's optimization problem as
follows he's going to try to boost the
the neural network score for the input
for some incorrect label relative to the
correct label over all inputs within
some epsilon perturbation of the nominal
input so the point is that this
optimization problem by itself could be
very difficult but I don't need to
compute the exact value of this optimum
like as long as I can bounded above by
zero essentially I have a proof that the
adversary cannot attack my model right
so so this allows us to essentially
somehow relax this optimization problem
that will allow us to get upper bounds
on the maximum value and if that
relaxation itself produces a bound
that's smaller than zero then
essentially we're down like that that's
the key idea so in order to do to set up
the relaxation you can think of the
competition being done in a neural
network as a set of constraints so
what's happening in a neural network so
you receive some input you apply some
simple transformation to it which is
apply some kind of affine mapping and
then pass it through something like this
then you get the activations at the neck
lair of the neural network and then
you're going to apply another such
transformation and then keep going until
you get the outputs right so it's just a
cascaded application of very simple
transformations of your input and we're
going to denote by n n of X the set of
scores for each of the possible labels
that the neural network can produce so
so if I try to write down the
adversarial optimization problem in
terms of this picture so I want to
maximize some linear function of the set
of scores that I that my new network
produces for all possible labels in this
case the C is just going to be a plus 1
minus 1 corresponding to the incorrect
and the correct label subject to the
constraint that at each layer the layer
L is going to be some transformation
applied to the activations at layer L
minus 1 and then I have that the
activations that layer 0 are equal to
the perturbed input and the perturbed
input is within epsilon of the anomaly
so essentially this is really the the
constraint that's difficult in terms of
optimization it's a non linear equality
constraint and so I'm going to do the
most natural thing I'm going to do a
Lagrangian relaxation of that I'm gonna
have a Lagrangian supplier that that
takes that constraint and relaxes it and
essentially by weak duality I know that
for any true choice of lambda this is
going to give me an upper bound on the
worst case adversarial perturbation and
so essentially as long as I can find you
a lambda lambda such that this map
maximum is smaller than 0 I have a proof
that my model is safe this is really
this is exactly what we're doing
so of course this is a relaxation and in
general the bounds could be quite loose
we're solving np-hard problems we were
able to analyze some special cases to
actually give some further guarantees on
on being able to compute tight bounds in
order to do this we have to make some
assumptions so we have to assume that
the the perturbations are constrained in
the two norm and we also make this very
strong assumption that we only have two
layers in the network so essentially we
have our input a single hidden layer and
the output layer under these assumptions
we can prove the following so there is a
constant Kappa that's a function of the
parameters of the neural network such
that if your perturbation radius is
smaller than Kappa we can actually solve
the verification problem exactly using a
projected gradient style algorithm so
you can actually compute the worst case
adversarial attack precisely using a
simple projected gradient algorithm and
and if if if epsilon is larger than that
we can still obtain an additive
approximation of the worst case
adversarial perturbation where the
approximation grows as epsilon cubed
times some factor that depends on the
parameters in unit
okay so so I just kind of want to
reinforce the advantage of viewing
verification in this way first of all we
can handle general networks and
architectures it applies to basically
every kind of feed-forward neural
network you might encounter in practice
it's an anytime algorithm in the sense
that I as long as I can produce any
value of lambdas for you I have a valid
bound on the adversarial objective sois
if I have a computational budget on the
verification I can stop at any time take
the values of lambda that I have and
essentially I'll put the bound that I
get from that it can handle fairly
general specifications in terms of
specific constraints on the inputs and
outputs of the model and and based on
the results I presented on the previous
slide we have special cases where we can
actually obtain exact or approximation
guarantees and and the final nice thing
about this is that because we go through
this dual approach we can essentially
integrate this very easily with learning
because we can essentially replace the
training objective for the neural
network with the dual function and
essentially by doing that you are
actually minimizing this upper bound on
the adversarial effect on your model so
so this is some results that we got
again counting the number of test
examples for this image classification
problem that don't have an adversarial
example within a radius of size Epsilon
so the these curves up here are from a
previous approach that that came out
earlier this year which basically mostly
computes vacuous bounds it's it's not
able to so so essentially at zero
perturbation of all the way all the
approaches give you a non-trivial bound
which is trivial but then as as soon as
you have a small perturbation these
previous bounds got pretty bad the
dashed lines are again the lower bounds
on the adversarial accuracy that we get
from the specific attack that we design
and the blue sorry the solid lines are
the verified bounds that we have so the
different colors just correspond to the
two five different neural networks that
we train for this task
you can apply this to more complicated
specifications so we looked at this
problem where you take a github
repository and sorry new question yes
yes so we looked at github repositories
and we looked at comets to these github
repositories over time and our goal is
to predict whether the repository will
reach a certain number of commits at the
end of two months so you can think of
this as kind some kind of evolving
prediction problem where based on
evolving features like the number of
commits so far or the number of
committed so far I want to make an
estimate of whether I will reach a
certain number of comets in this kind of
problem it's desirable that your
classifier doesn't keep switching
between yes and no right so you don't
want a classifier that says that yes I
will reach a certain number of commits
and then suddenly switches to no and
then switches to yes again so this kind
of phenomenon this kind of phenomenon is
undesirable right so you say yes for
some time then you say no then you say
yes then you say no again you don't want
this to happen and so you want some
bound on the number of times your
classifier actually makes this switch
between yes and no and based on our
verification approach we can actually
get bounds on that as well the green is
the is a verified upper bound on up to
so if you look at day 60 this number
means the fraction of the times the
fraction of days on which the classifier
switches prediction from yes to no up to
this day right and then the red is
basically an attack that tries to
maximize the number of switches and so
this shows that you can actually get
very tight verification bounds
the reason the curves are fuzzy is that
this is averaged over a large number of
repositories you can also do other kinds
of tasks like the one that I mentioned
where you want to predict a sum of
digits and and you want to make sure
that you continue to predict the correct
sum in spite of perturbations I'll skip
over those results because I really want
to kind of talk about this this
idea of learning verifies for a few
minutes if I have that is okay okay cool
so essentially we want to fold the
verification into the learning process
and in order to make this
computationally tractable what we
figured that is that we can actually use
another neural network to do the
verification itself so we can get a new
network that given the input image
actually predicts these dual variables
that we do the verification with and
once we have the dual variables you can
actually get a bound on the adversarial
error rate and you can simultaneously
train these two neural networks the
predictor and this verifier together and
this gives us a much more tractable
approach than all the previous
algorithms and so you have this kind of
verified learning approach where you
have your training algorithm and you
have your verification algorithm and
both of them are feeding off of each
other trying to learn as robust a model
as possible and so with this approach we
are able to so let's ignore the blue and
the green points these these two are the
points to focus on this was the previous
state-of-the-art verified model based on
this paper that came out earlier this
year we used exactly the same neural
network architecture and we are able to
get a better adversarial bound with a
better nominal performance so we are
able to improve on both dimensions and
we are also able to improve on the
training time so this approach took
about five hours to train this model on
comparable hardware we take just about
20 minutes and the main idea that gives
us those savings is is this idea of
using a neural network to do the
verification itself that amortizes the
cost over all the test examples
I think I kind of touched upon a lot of
issues I think as a theory audience I
think there's a lot of interesting
questions for you guys in this space of
course there's this issue of when can
verification be done attractively we had
some results for single hidden layer
networks can we extend this beyond
there's also this issue of theoretical
foundations right so essentially when we
did this idea of integrating the
verification into the learning algorithm
what we found is that by doing this we
actually learn models that are easy to
verify so if you just train some model
based on some agnostic approach and then
try to verify it it tends to be much
harder to verify then if you feed the
verification back into the learning
since they're some kind of theoretical
basis we can give for this phenomenon I
think that would be really interesting a
deep mind we have a lot of expertise in
reinforcement learning and you can
imagine doing more sophisticated types
of verification that actually require
some kind of common a total search
within the verification process and a
lot of these verification problems have
common structure and so the question is
can you use the enforcement learning to
guide the process of verification and
fun finally there is this interesting
question of fundamental trade-offs which
I think a lot of people in in controls
worry about is how do is there a
fundamental trade-off between nominal
and robust performance of the model what
is the Pareto frontier of possibilities
that I can achieve if you start to add
more and more specifications can i
compute these multi-dimensional Pareto
frontiers I think that's that's a very
interesting question to look at also I
want to mention that we are hiring
especially in in this space of at the
intersection of four methods controls in
and learning so if you're interested
come and talk to me you can come and
work in one of these cool offices and
I'll leave you with this picture and
yeah that's it thank you
right so we're we're a ways away from
being able to verify something like a
self-driving car so the idea would be
that given some kind of formal model of
the environment in which the car is
operating can you verify that it would
satisfy some property like never getting
close enough to some obstacle I yeah
this is something that requires thought
I I haven't this is the no-no so okay so
I what I would argue to you is that if
you let's say that there was some way to
come up with a formal model of the
environment in which the self-driving
car was operating right now presumably
the self-driving car depends on
perception systems that that use some
kind of image recognition algorithms and
if your image image recognition systems
are not even robust in the senses that I
was talking about there is no way that
you could verify any kind of safety
property no matter what the formal model
is yeah
like you know the car's not gonna take
solar lights from hundreds miles per
hour to zero right
yeah so so one example that actually
drove a lot of the initial verification
work is this paper called Rayleigh Plex
that came out of Stanford a year back
where they were working with the FAA on
the affair has defined some set of rules
that they want like autonomous drones to
satisfy and there are things like you
know if you detect an intruder and the
intruder is actually accelerating
towards you in a certain direction you
don't want to recommend an action that
forces the drone towards that turns
closer towards so there's these like
sanity rules that can be defined purely
as input/output properties of the neural
network which may may not be sufficient
to guarantee safety overall but there
are at least reasonable sanity checks
that you can impose the model that you
have in propagation and all that things
we do in game theory and you have
controls you know this has been a
classical model right it's control the
controller is adding its control the
state is propagating yeah attack by the
adversary when you put the max over
epsilon blah blah blah and then you have
you're essentially doing a minimization
when you are training the neural
networks weights are essentially the
controlled variable
yes it is a minimax problem yes and I'm
in that sense it is a zero-sum game yeah
but I mean I don't know that I don't
obviously see any
any useful results we can relish from
game theory but if you think that there
are I'd be happy to talk to you offline
minimizing Hamiltonians and controls and
so there are lots of algorithms within
controls and games into them they do
this open loop control configuration and
open group attacks computation and I
think some of the tools from there may
be through something or I don't know I
think that would be great yeah I'd be
happy to talk to you offline about that
so it's the theoretical results that
only apply to two layer networks where
the theoretical results about being able
to do verification exactly being able to
compute bounds we can do for an
arbitrary number of layers
it's just proving that those bounds
would be tight we can only do for
special cases so so this is a very
tricky question to answer so what we
found in our experiments is that if you
train networks without having this
verification as feedback then you can
quickly get to networks that are very
difficult to verify and the bounds kind
of kind of explore as the number of
layers grow or as the number of neurons
grow but as long if you do this idea of
folding the verification back into the
training we are able to train rather
deep networks that are still easy to
verify and the gap between the bounds is
small so it's the the the gap is not a
simple function of the number of layers
of the number of neurons it actually
depends fundamentally
yeah formalizes problem I get in my talk
in the sense it you hope that box they
give you guys or no you don't have time
to check all the possible questions and
maybe you also know that you want you to
get here so that one side of the world
and not for the other side there is kind
of active learning problem when you ask
where is the equation that they need to
graph at the minimum number your high my
space looks like this makes sense yes in
in in principal it makes sense
I don't see an easy way to come up with
a proof that says that if you verified
this these K points then you know that
you're safe everywhere else
but I'd be interested to talk to you
offline about the functional this is
this then I seem to miss question before
something like this that's expected then
I think this can be no using active
learning my mission a we can actually
get good trade-off between number of
questions and how you what you learn
Apollo the world on earth right yeah
okay on in this tango to speaker
[Applause]